since its
inception in the 1950s the field of
artificial intelligence has vacillated
between periods of optimistic
predictions and massive investment
and periods of disappointment loss of
confidence
and reduced funding even with today's
seemingly
fast pace of ai breakthroughs the
development of long-promised
technologies
such as self-driving cars housekeeping
robots
and conversational companions has turned
out to be much harder
than many people expected professor
melanie mitchell thinks
one reason for these repeating cycles is
our limited understanding
of the nature and complexity of
intelligence itself
overconfident predictions about ai are
as old
as the field itself in 1958 for example
the new york times reported on a
demonstration by the u.s navy
of frank rosenblatt's perceptron which
was a precursor to today's neural
networks
they said the navy revealed the embryo
of an electronic computer today that it
expects
will be able to walk talk see
write and reproduce itself and be
conscious of its own existence
in 1960 the ai pioneer herbert simon
declared that
machines will be capable within 20 years
of doing any work that a man can do the
following year
claude shannon echoed this prediction
saying that he confidently expected that
within a matter of
10 or 15 years something will emerge
from the laboratory
which is not too far from the robot of
science fiction fame
[Music]
and a few years later marvin minsky
predicted
that within a generation the problems of
creating artificial intelligence
will be substantially solved
by the latter part of the 1980s these
optimistic hopes
had all been dashed again none of these
technologies had achieved the lofty
promises
that had been made
[Music]
expert systems which rely on humans to
create rules that capture
expert knowledge of a particular domain
turned out to be brittle
that is to say often unable to
generalize
or adapt when faced with new situations
the problem was that human experts
writing the rules
actually relied on subconscious
knowledge
what you might call common sense that
was not part of the system's programming
[Music]
the 1990s and 2000s saw the meteoric
rise of machine learning the development
of algorithms which create
predictive models from data
these approaches were typically inspired
by statistics
rather than neuroscience or psychology
and were aimed at performing specific
tasks rather than capturing general
intelligence
machine learning practitioners were
often quick to differentiate
their discipline from the then
discredited field of artificial
intelligence
soon after alex krachewski's imagenet
moment deep learning
emerged from the last position in the
pack and rose to superstar prominence
this led to an unrelenting maelstrom of
hype and optimistic future predictions
stuart russell co-author of a widely
used textbook on ai
predicted that super intelligent ai will
probably happen in the lifetime of his
children
sam altman the ceo of openai predicted
that within decades
computer programs would do almost
everything
including making new scientific
discoveries that will expand our concept
of everything
shane legg the co-founder of google
deepmind predicted in 2008 that
human level ai will be passed in the
mid-2020s
and facebook ceo mark zuckerberg
declared in 2015
that one of facebook's goals for the
next five to ten years
is to basically get better than human
level at all of the primary human senses
vision hearing language
and general cognition however
as melanie points out it didn't take
long for cracks to appear
in the deep learning facade of
intelligence it turns out that
like all ai systems of the past deep
learning systems
also suffer from brittleness
unpredictable errors
when facing situations that differ from
the training data
one of the main reasons for this is that
deep learning systems are susceptible
to shortcut learning which is to say
learning statistical associations in the
training data
that allow the machine to produce
correct answers
but sometimes for the wrong reasons
the sources of their brittleness and
vulnerability are still not completely
understood
these networks with their large number
of parameters
are complicated systems their
decision-making mechanisms are almost
completely
opaque the non-human-like errors and
vulnerability to adversarial examples
are strong indicators that these systems
are not actually
understanding the data that they process
at least not in the human sense
something
fundamental is still missing
and the other thing is that deep
learning systems require
big data large scale vision and language
models are only possible
because of the billions of images and
documents which are now accessible on
the internet
if you've ever uploaded an image to
flickr it's possible that your image
is now part of the imagenet training set
if you've ever had to prove that you're
not a robot
your metadata might now be used by
google to tag an image
microsoft researchers eric horvitz said
that
right now what we're doing is not a
science it's a form of alchemy
and dennis hassibilis from deepmind says
it's almost like
an art form to get the best out of these
systems there's only a few hundred
people
in the world who are experts at doing it
well
um mark serafin was on our show recently
and he pointed out in his great
stagnation article
that there's a new priesthood class in
artificial intelligence
with the phd program now becoming the
extended interview process
for the prestigious tech industry jobs
one of the reasons for the success of
this youtube channel and other similar
youtube channels
is that many aspirational data
scientists want to make six-figure
salaries
training a neural network with more than
five layers
and seven figures if it has more than 50
layers
luckily for these aspirational people
the networks
cannot yet teach themselves
most people in artificial intelligence
trace the field's official
founding to a small workshop in 1956
at dartmouth college organized by a
young mathematician
named john mccarthy even though the most
advanced computers at the time
were about a million times slower than
today's smartphones
mccarthy and colleagues were optimistic
that ai was in close
reach obstacles soon arose of course
that would be familiar to anyone
organizing a scientific workshop today
the rockefeller foundation came through
with only half the requested amount of
funding
and it turned out to be harder than
mccarthy had thought to persuade the
participants
to actually come and then stay not to
mention
agree on anything there were lots of
interesting discussions but
not a lot of coherence as usual in such
meetings
everyone had a different idea a hearty
ego
and much enthusiasm for their own plan
the soon to be big four pioneers of the
field mccarthy
minsky alan newell and herbert simon
met and did some planning for the future
right from the very beginning there were
many different schools of thought
about how to achieve artificial
intelligence mathematicians generally
promoted
mathematical logic and deductive
reasoning as the language of rational
thought
others championed inductive methods
where programs
extract statistics from data and use
probabilities
to deal with uncertainty still others
believe firmly in taking inspiration
from biology
and psychology to create brain-like
programs
the fascinating thing is now in 2021
we're having exactly the same arguments
human intelligence is a marvelous subtle
and poorly understood phenomenon there's
no danger of duplicating it
time soon and also the roboticist
and former director of mit's ai lab
rodney brooks
agreed stating that we grossly
overestimate the capabilities of
machines
those of today and of the next few
decades
the psychologist and ai researcher gary
marcus who we've had on the show
went so far as to assert that the quest
to create strong ai
that is general human level ai there's
been
almost no progress made
hi i'm leticia you might not know me
but you might know miss coffee bean from
the ai coffee break youtube channel
together with the guys from mlst i had
the honor today
of speaking to melanie mitchell who is
the davis professor of complexity at the
santa fe
institute and professor of computer
science at
portland state university her current
research focuses
on conceptual abstraction analogy making
and visual recognition in artificial
intelligence systems
melanie is the author or editor of
six books and numerous scholarly papers
in the fields of artificial intelligence
cognitive science and complex systems
her latest book is artificial
intelligence
a guide for thinking human in melanie's
book
she explores how intelligent the best ai
programs really are and how they work
and when they fail she discusses how
human-like we expect them to become and
how soon we need to worry about them
surpassing
us melanie wanted to understand
the true affairs in artificial
intelligence
what computers can do now and what we
can expect from them
over the next decades what do we
actually mean
by general human or even super
human intelligence is currently i
close to this level or even on a
trajectory to get there
melanie originated the santa fe
institute's complexity
explorer platform which offers online
courses and other educational resources
related to the field of complex systems
her online course
introduction to complexity has been
taken
by over 25 000 students and is one of
the core
central's top 50 online courses of all
time
melanie's phd was supervised by douglas
hofstetter a legend in ai
and the author of a famous book
cryptically titled
godel escher bach an eternal golden
braid
or more succinctly geb if you're a
computer scientist or a computer
enthusiast you've probably heard of it
or read it or tried to read it written
in the 1970s
gb was an outpouring of hofstetter's
many intellectual
passions like mathematics art music
language
humor and wordplay all brought together
to address the deep
questions of how intelligence
consciousness
and the sense of self-awareness that
each human
experiences so fundamentally can emerge
from the
non-intelligent non-conscious substrate
of biological cells
it's also about how intelligence and
self-awareness might eventually be
attained by
computers it's a unique book and it's
not an easy read
and yet it became a bestseller and won
both the pulitzer prize
and the national book award without a
doubt gb inspired more young people to
pursue ai than any other book melanie
was one of them
and she persuaded hofstetter to take her
on
as a research assistant first for a
summer
and then for the next six years as a
graduate student
after which she graduated with a
doctorate in computer science from
michigan
i hope you enjoyed this discussion with
melanie at least as much as miss coffee
bean did
this is a clip of douglas hofstadter
talking at stanford
if we are going to make any connection
between analogy and
a geographical situation we're going to
liken it to the interstate freeway
system
and it links everything together analogy
as the interstate freeway system of
cognition it is not
one little tiny zone somewhere off in
the side
it's so that's uh that's a kind of a a
way of
that i think about it i mean i don't
really usually think about it that way i
made that up yesterday so
that gives you the flavor categorization
is the name of the cognition game
but analogy is the mechanism that
creates or that allows categorization to
happen
by categorization i mean uh deciding
what something is
what the essence of something is now one
could sort of summarize this in a corny
little analogy again analogy is the
motor of the car of thought
and then we then can even write it down
as this
little thing analogy is to thinking as
a motor is to a car a is to be
as c is to d analogy making is the
perception of common essence between two
things
and then a couple of footnotes to sort
of hedge
i mean things don't have essences but
what i mean i'm not a you know i'm not
talking about some kind of abstract
glowing philosophical essence i'm
talking about the essence that you
perceive
at the particular time in the frame of
mind that you happen to be in
and uh and by when i say things it's
tempting to think that the analogies are
between the
things in the external world but i
really want to say that analogies happen
inside your head so that they're
they're they're connections between two
mental representations they're
connections between things inside your
head
uh which we project to the outside world
and we say these things outside
out there are analogous and that's very
reasonable to do
[Music]
demine's original mission statement was
solve intelligence
and use it to solve everything else
there was a meeting booked at the
googleplex a group of select google ai
researchers wanted to hear from
and converse with the main man douglas
hofstadter
hofstadter invited melanie to join him
for the discussion hofstadter got up to
speak
and he said he had some remarks about ai
research in general
and there at google in particular his
voice became
passionate he said i'm terrified
i'm terrified hofstadter went on
he described how when he first started
working on ai
in the 1970s it was an exciting prospect
but it just seemed so far from being
realized
there was no danger on the horizon chess
mastery though
once seen as the pinnacle of human
intelligence
had since succumbed to a brute force
search
hofstadter asked will a computer ever
write beautiful music
there was speculation yes
but not soon hofstadter continued
he said that music is a language of
emotions
and until programs have emotions as
complex as ours
there's no way a program will write
anything beautiful
i mean yeah there can be forgeries
shallow imitations of the syntax of
earlier music
but despite what one might think at
first there's much
more to musical expression than could be
captured in the syntactic rules
to think that we might soon be able to
command
a pre-programmed mass-produced
mail-order 20
desk model music box to bring forth from
its sterile circuitry
pieces which chopper or bark might have
written had they lived a little bit
longer
it's a grotesque and shameful
misestimation
of the depth of the human spirit
hofstadter lamented a recent musical
generation
program called emi it's written by a
musician called david cope
it could produce music in the style of
shop r
it didn't sound exactly like shopper but
it sounded enough like shopper
and it sounded like coherent music
so this made hofstadter feel deeply
troubled
ever since hofstadter was a child music
had thrilled him
and moved him to the very core every
piece that he loved
felt like it was a direct message from
the emotional heart of the human being
who composed it it felt like it was
giving
him access to their innermost soul
and it felt like there was nothing more
human in the world
than the expression of music nothing
hofstadter then recounted a lecture that
he gave at the prestigious
eastman school of music in new york
after describing emi hofstadter asked
the audience
including several music theory and
composition faculty
to guess which of two pieces a pianist
played for them
were they the real thing or a shallow
facade
generated by emi
to hof status dire shock many of the
faculty agreed that the emi piece
was an unknown but genuine chopper
the correct answers were the reverse
in the google conference room hofstadter
paused peering into their faces
no one said a word at last
he went on he said he was terrified by
emi
terrified he hated it he was extremely
threatened by it it was threatening to
destroy
what he most cherished about humanity he
thought that emi
was the most quintessential example
of the fears that he had about
artificial intelligence
[Music]
hofstadter ended the talk with a direct
reference to the very google engineers
in the room
all listening intently he said he found
it very scary
very troubling very sad and he found it
terrible horrifying bizarre baffling
bewildering that people were rushing
ahead
blindly and deliriously creating these
things
hostats terror was in response not
about the ai becoming too smart too
invasive
too malicious or even too useful
instead he was terrified that
intelligence
creativity emotions and maybe even
consciousness itself would be all too
easy
to produce that what he valued most in
humanity
would end up being nothing more than a
bag of tricks
that a superficial set of brute force
algorithms could explain
the human spirit hofstadter firmly
believes that the mind
and all of its characteristics emerge
wholly
from the physical substrate of the brain
and the rest of the body
along with the body's interaction with
the physical world
there's nothing immaterial or
incorporeal lurking there
the issue that worries him is really one
of complexity
he fears that ai might show us the human
qualities we most
value are disappointingly simple to
mechanize
as hofstadter explained to melanie after
the meeting here referring to shopah
bach and other paragons of humanity if
such
minds of infinite subtlety and
complexity and emotional depth
can be trivialized by a small chip
it would destroy his sense of what
humanity
is all about
melanie believes that there are four
fallacies in common assumptions made by
ai researchers
which can lead to overconfident
predictions about the field
fallacy number one narrow intelligence
is on a continuum
with general intelligence now thinking
that building taller towers to get
closer to the moon
or getting a high salary job would get
you closer to being a billionaire
it's flawed intelligence is the ultimate
deceptive objective
we simply don't know what the
intermediate stepping stones are to
achieve it
fallacy number two easy things are easy
and hard things are hard while john
mccarthy lamented that ai was
harder than we thought marvin minsky
explained that this is because easy
things
are hard that's to say the things that
we humans do
without much thought you know looking up
on the world
making sense of what we see carrying on
a conversation
walking down a crowded sidewalk without
bumping into anyone
you know these things turn out to be the
hardest challenges for machines
conversely it's often easier to get
machines to do things that are very hard
for humans
for example solving complex mathematical
challenges or playing board games really
well
researchers at google deepmind spoke of
alphago's
triumph they described the game of go as
being
one of the most challenging of domains
but is it actually that challenging for
computers
for humans sure as psychologist gary
marcus who we had on the show pointed
out
there are domains including games that
while easy for humans
are much more challenging than go for ai
systems
one example is charades which requires
acting skills
linguistic skills and a theory of mind
albeit these are far beyond anything ai
can accomplish today
marvin minsky once said that in general
we're least aware
of what our minds do best fallacy number
three
the lure of wistful mnemonics the term
wishful mnemonic was
coined in 1976 by the computer scientist
drew mcdermott it refers to the terms
that were used to describe ai programs
and their evaluation benchmarks often
naming terms after the skills we hope
that they test for example in nlp we
have the stanford question answering
data set
the reading comprehension data set and
the general language understanding
evaluation
deepmind's david silva said we can ask
alphago
how well it thinks it's doing during the
game
it was only towards the end of the game
that alphago thought
that it would win melanie thinks that
the constant anthropomorphization ai
is misleading the public understanding
of artificial intelligence
and unconsciously shaping the way that
ai
experts think about their systems and
how closely these systems resemble human
intelligence
fallacy 4 intelligence is in the brain
the idea that intelligence is something
that can be separated from the body
whether it's a non-physical substance or
as a wholly encapsulated in the brain
has a long history in philosophy and
cognitive science
computationalism or the information
processing model of the mind
arose in psychology in the mid 20th
century
this model views the mind as a kind of
computer
which inputs stores processes and
outputs information the body
does not play much of a role except in
the input and output stages
under this view cognition takes place
wholly in the brain it opens up the door
to a kind of
pure intelligence in many ways in my
opinion
this is intellectually lazy you know
this line of thinking
opens the door to notions of runaway
super intelligence
or the creation of intelligence which is
independent
of emotions or the limitations of the
physical body
the assumption that intelligence is all
in the brain has led to speculation
that to achieve high level human level
ai
we simply need to scale up the machines
to match the brain's computing capacity
and then develop the appropriate
software
embedded cognition means that the
representation of conceptual knowledge
is dependent on the body it's
multi-modal and low level
embodiment implies that our thoughts are
grounded or inextricably
associated with perception action
and emotion and that our brain and body
work together
for cognition to emerge anyway for those
of you who are interested in some of
these ideas
i strongly recommend you listen to our
show with professor
mark bishop by the way i'm really sorry
about the poor audio quality from
melanie's microphone on
the show today we're not 100 sure what
the cause of the problem was
at street talk we pride ourselves on
production quality
having the best possible production
quality and this definitely falls below
our standards
i've done everything possible to clean
up melanie's audio but her microphone
was only sampled at about eight
kilohertz
giving us a maximum representable
frequency of four kilohertz as those
who know about the nyquist theorem would
attest but um anyway it sounds a bit
like she's talking on the phone
so we'll make sure this never happens
again i mean frankly the combined amount
of work
that the entire team puts into preparing
for these shows
a 200 microphone is like a drop in the
ocean we should have just sent it to
melanie
you know melanie's audio is still
intelligible but it's a real shame that
the quality wasn't better
it's been my dream to get melanie on the
show for such a long time now
she's such a huge inspiration for me and
i wanted it to be as good quality as it
possibly could have been
so anyway please bear with it um it was
still an amazing show
and we'll see you back next week melanie
it's an absolute honour to have you on
the show
i think you might be the perfect guest
for me personally actually because i
love your style
and i agree with you on absolutely
everything or maybe that doesn't make
you a good
guest i'm not sure but i've just read
melanie's book artificial intelligence
a guide for thinking humans it's
honestly one of the best books on ai
that i've ever read
i had to keep reminding myself that this
book was written by a computer science
professor
melanie's style of writing is extremely
accessible and uses plain language
i read i read a lot of technical
manuscripts preparing for this show
and it's got to the point now where i
immediately recognize good prose
technical content doesn't have to be
written with high register latin it
language
gary marcus and francois charles by the
way are also extremely good at writing
and they have a similar kind of
pragmatic
no-nonsense outlook to to melanie
anyway as an example of melanie's prose
when she was describing how
reinforcement learning worked in her
book
and its pitfalls and some of the deep
mind implementations
i couldn't believe how succinctly
explained it was and using so
few words compared to what i would have
done it's a classic case of when people
understand things deeply
they can explain it simply i really
enjoyed melanie's book
and i'm actually really inspired to read
her previous book which is complexity a
guided tour
and that was an amazon top 10 science
book
now melanie recently published a paper
called why ai is harder than we think
where she outlined four key
misunderstandings in current ai research
and in my opinion melanie is one of the
most important voices in the ai world
right now
that is to say the voice of reason and
pragmatism
melanie is also an outspoken critic of
ai risk
we spoke about this with jeff hawkins
last week and i don't think we'll go
into it too much today as melanie's
spoken a lot about it online
but i agree with melanie that progress
on
giving computers moral intelligence
cannot be separated
from progress on other types of
intelligence so the true challenge is to
create machines
that have common sense and can actually
understand the situations that they
confront
cause and affect relationships imagining
different possible futures
and understanding the beliefs and goals
of others
but anyway um check melanie's book to to
get more on her take on that
so melanie you said at the end of your
europe's talk that abstraction
and analogy making an ai is still wide
open
much like it was in 1955 at the
dartmouth summer workshop proposal
with the go-fi leading lights at the
time it's almost as if we haven't gotten
that far
since and you said that the core problem
of intelligence which is in your view
flexibility
and overcoming brittleness still hasn't
been solved
contrast this with the unrelenting
deluge of hype around artificial
intelligence
i read a bbc article this morning with
the headline ai breakthrough could spark
medical revolution the article added
fuel to the fire by saying that nature
was a prestigious journal
and described the achievement as being a
giant leap without using any quotation
marks
and you wouldn't really expect that from
a supposedly unbiased news source so
melanie do you think this hype is
getting out of control
so it says so there is a lot of hype in
ai or you know as there always has been
since the very beginning of the field
this most recent uh
sort of leap if you will by uh deep mind
on
protein folding actually perhaps is one
of the first things that deserves some
some of the hype uh i'm not an expert on
uh protein folding prediction but i do
think that they have accomplished
something really great but
you know what's really interesting is
it's very specific problem it's not sort
of
general a.i and it's
really uh it it in a sort of assistance
to humans rather than replacing humans
and that's perhaps where ai is actually
going to
really succeed uh
there has been a huge amount of hype of
course around
progress in ai's such as gpt-3 being
able to
generate human-like text and and you
know more recently
a version of gpt-3 that can
sort of produce code you know we heard
about the you know the github copilot
things like that there has been a huge
amount of hype in the media
but also by companies
in their press releases and even by
scientists in their
social media posts although people tend
to be a little more careful in their
academic papers
so i think that it's nothing new ai has
been subject to hype
for generations and
possibly because it's called artificial
intelligence
which you know sounds so
science-fictiony to to people and and
it's kind of uh
just asking for hype absolutely on the
subject of gbt3 i wanted to get to that
later but we might as well do it now
quickly
um i read your blog post at the time
talking about the letter analogies and i
know that you did a lot of work with
letter analogies under douglas
hofstadter
and i was quite surprised actually
because i i reproduced many of your
experiments on gbt3 and i cited them on
our
epic video that we made and um when you
do the bike pair encoding so
gbt3 uses bike pair encoding so when you
have spaces between the letters
it works much better and it works
remarkably well in general
but what do you think is actually going
on with gbt3 on those letter analogies
that's a great question um you know it's
a little hard to tell
gpt3 is uh not very transparent into how
it works
um you know i i'm
i think a lot of these language models
are
as mysterious and and it's
unclear to what extent they're kind of
memorizing
their training data and and spitting it
out perhaps
a slightly different paraphrase form or
actually have have learned some kind of
conceptual representation of
uh the world and
the the user through this vast amount of
language that they've
sort of digested so i think that's one
of the things that
ai researchers should be looking at is
sort of what is it that these models
have actually
learned and how is it that we can
actually probe them to make sense of
what they've learned
and that's something that i'm really
interested in working on and i think
that
a lot more of that needs to be done so i
guess the answer is i don't know what
it's doing why
why it has the behavior it has you know
it it does very well on certain kinds of
inputs and analogies and so on and but
then it can
just uh completely fail sometimes and
there's a whole new
uh sort of expertise area now called
prompt engineering which is where you
have to
carefully uh design the prompt you give
to these systems like gpt3
to get the kind of results that you want
and that's
in some sense an intelligence test
because we humans don't need
prompt engineering you know you know to
to most
the great extent you can ask me a
question in many many different ways and
i'll understand you but
um that's the kind of flexibility we
want clearly
yeah and about that about that prompt
engineering you've also made the point
previously that the ability to kind of
dynamically refocus
or uh you know query new bits of
information is kind of a hallmark of
intelligence and one of the reasons why
you're skeptical that
deep learning as it stands today which
is some finite
or fixed forward pass you know kind of
computation will ever work
because in the case of gpt3 it's just
going to give you an
answer whether it understands you or not
it doesn't have the capability to say
i'm not really sure what you meant there
can you rephrase that which people do
right we have that capability i'm
wondering if you can tie that in
yes so knowing what questions to ask is
is also key
to to intelligence and understanding
and i don't know if anybody's ever tried
to get gpt3 to sort of
ask the right questions uh i doubt that
it can do that
i haven't tried but you're right i think
sort of refocusing figuring out sort of
what you don't understand and how to
actually gain the information you need
to understand it that's
sort of active engagement
with the world or with uh another
uh someone you're communicating with
that's really important yeah there's
something fascinating as well because
we'll get to
um hofstra shortly but he said that
concepts are like a package of analogies
and then
gpt3 to a certain extent has memorized
um analogies being used in lots of
different situations so again hofstadter
in his book surfaces and essences he
spoke about sour grapes you know the
abstract category
and when there are so many examples of
sour grapes being used in everyday
language then you'd be forgiven for
thinking that gbt3 understood it but
perhaps it's the
sensitivity to create new abstract
analogies which is where the real
intelligence lies but
i wanted to quickly get to your paper i
really enjoyed reading it why ai is
harder than we think
and you came up with kind of four really
important
things that we should be looking at in
that paper could you give us an outline
sure so i talked about sort of these
recurring cycles of optimism
and disappointment in ai that people
sometimes called ai
spring and ai winter where people have
sort of hyped up or or made grand
promises for their systems
and then they don't work as well as
people had
had promised and then there's
disappointment so we've seen that
since the beginning of the field and it
continues today
and i think it has to do with
our sort of misunderstanding
or i call them fallacies about sort of
the nature of intelligence itself
so one one of the the first fallacy and
i would say that
you know these are not new necessarily
people have talked about these in
different ways
uh so but i wanted to bring them
together as
my review why we're it's hard to predict
where we are
or assess where we are in ai progress so
the first fallacy was that
um
narrow ai is on a continuum
with general ai so that the idea there
is that we make
progress in some narrow tasks like
speech recognition
or machine translation or what have you
playing go
that that's a step towards general
intelligence
and in fact hubert dreyfus a philosopher
who wrote
a book a long time ago called
what computers still can't do uh
calls this the first step fallacy where
people say
you know gpt3 is the first step towards
general ai
or ibm watson is the first step towards
general cognition
and you know these are things that uh
people actually do say
quite a lot but there might not be a
continuum there it might not be just a
series of steps like that and
dreyfus in fact said that there is a
discontinuity and it's called the common
sense problem
which we can talk about what that means
that
these systems are running into this
barrier of common sense
and none of them can get over it the
second fallacy
was um what what i called
easy things are easy and hard things are
hard so that's the idea that things that
seem very easy to us
turn out to be very hard for machines
and
vice versa so playing go or playing
chess and beating
the grand master seems to be a pinnacle
of intelligence for humans
but it's something that machines are
able to do and
in fact dennis demus costibis who's the
co-founder of deepmind called go the
most
challenging of domains but the question
is most challenging for whom
certainly challenging for me or for
other humans
but uh it it's not necessarily the most
challenging for a machine
so gary marcus who you've i think you've
had on the show um
talked about the game of charades which
is something that
any six-year-old can play but it's far
beyond any machine because it requires
visual understanding
theory of mind all these things that
machines
don't have so something that might seem
very easy for us
turns out to be very hard for machines
and and people have called this
morbeck's paradox because hans moorevec
talked about it
marvin minsky talked about it it it's
a fallacy to think that just because
you've solved something that's very hard
for humans
that therefore you're
closer to general a.i
so then there's a third fallacy called
what i call the lure of wishful
mnemonics
so wishful mnemonics is a wonderful term
that was proposed
actually in 1976 by drew mcdermott an ai
researcher from yale
where he talked about using
anthropomorphic terms to describe
ai systems and we see that today you
know
we even use terms like artificial
intelligence
machine learning deep learning uh
machine reading we talk about these
abilities you know general language
understanding that's something
these are the names of like benchmark
data sets
but these terms in the sense of machines
mean something very different than what
they mean for humans so like
when when ibm says watson can read all
the uh medical textbooks
uh in a matter of of hours
it's not actually reading the way that
we read it doesn't understand what it
reads in the same way so that makes
but it kind of leads us astray so
i think this notion of wishful mnemonics
uh is very
uh it can definitely mislead not only
the general public but also researchers
themselves
and the final let me just say the final
fallacy which i actually got a
lot of negative feedback a lot of
negative emails about
is this claim that intelligence is all
in the brain
which is the idea that the body doesn't
matter we can kind of sift off
intelligence and implement it in a
machine without worrying about
all of the embodiment issues that human
intelligence
uh seems to rely on so i definitely got
that one a lot of people disagreed on
it's very controversial
so those are my fallacies and i use
those to
sort of say why i think we tend to
overestimate
uh the advances that we see in ai as
being
getting us towards more general
human-like intelligence
yeah and i would like to relate a little
now on the third
fallacy about the wishful mnemonics
because i'm a little
interested to really get some actionable
item out of that and i'm interested
especially how
you think about it because you're a very
down-to-earth person
and for me i mean it's hard to
disentangle
wishful mnemonics from for example
really useful terms to explain something
especially to laymen so
or even to my peers that are not really
researching in
exactly that topic that i am into and if
i'm writing a function
i won't call it g0023 just because
it's hard to read i i understand it's
highly misleading if i call it
goal or reasoning or thinking or
understanding
but um yeah how how do you
think about it because for me it's
harder said than done just to
avoid wishful mnemonics because it's
the easiest way to make this parallel
between what i'm
teaching and teaching is again a wishful
mnemonic to a machine
and uh what i'm actually doing in code
yeah i also find it very difficult and
humans are
very um
they tend to anthropomorphize everything
anything that seems to have any kind of
agency and this this is even for the
the dumbest ai systems you know go go
back to
eliza the the chat bot that joseph
weisenbaum built
back in the maybe the 60s i'm not sure
uh that that
uh tried to uh mimic a psychotherapist
so you would mention something about
your mother and it would have some
template or
say tell me more about your mother and
people
really believe that it was understanding
them because
they have this this propensity to
anthropomorphize
uh and that can be sometimes a good
thing
you know maybe if we want to build
interfaces with humans where they
you know can talk to in natural ways to
the the
interface uh that might be a good thing
but
it also can fool us so we have
i don't know if there's a actionable
thing we can do there
but we have to be more aware of it and
also in in
communicating with the public i think we
have to be much more
careful in if we're really going to give
people the
idea of what these machines are able to
do as opposed
as opposed to kind of fool them into
thinking that machines are much
more robust and trustworthy than they
are we have to be clearer in our
language
and it's not easy you know it can be
quite uh
awkward and i'm not sure exactly how to
do it but it's something to think about
yeah it's something that you've
mentioned
a lot in in your papers and in your book
melanie
uh you know the risk of
anthropomorphization in in ai
and part of how we anthropomorphize deep
learning models is based on the flawed
assumption
that they learn in a similar way to how
humans learn
the first difference is that humans
learn interactively with their
environment and have thousands of
multi-modal input sensors to draw upon
they infer abstractions and connections
between
concepts as they explore the world i
mean clearly neural networks don't learn
on their own as as you've said
in your book um but you might make the
argument that humans don't exactly have
tons of agency either
i know sam harris would have something
to say about this but um you said in
your eurips talk that
language based tasks actually increases
the risk of anthropomorphization so
what do you think we should do to to
manage this right
well i always find it very strange that
that ai people try and
focus on language before they
focus on sort of the basic
concepts that babies learn
pre-linguistically you know
and i can see why we want it we want to
have
tools useful tools that deal with the
actual language you know machine
translation is very useful
um speech recognition
chat box they can all be useful tools
but if we're actually getting machines
to try and understand things
um as opposed to just be some useful
tool i
i think that putting language first is
sort of the cart before the horse
so for instance in trying to teach
machines common sense
there's been a lot of efforts over the
years and a lot of them
start with sort of natural language
let's teach the machines
uh things in natural language like
you can't be in two places at the same
time you know little
rules of common sense uh but
there you know there's just so much
richness in these
terms for us these terms like even place
or
time that it are are based in our human
understanding on
all kinds of physical interactions with
the world
that we had as babies that to like put
the language
first seems to be to me the wrong way
around
could i just ask a quick follow-up on
that before you get to the part four
keith
um i wanted your opinion on
are these concepts kind of immutable
and can you boil them down to primitives
because we spoke we speak with
go-fi people all the time and they think
that you can
distill these concepts down to
primitives that would exist universally
even if the universe didn't exist
transitivity would still exist right and
could you then use those primitives to
um
you know if you compose them together
correctly you could
represent any high-level abstract
concept or because you know when you
were talking about your copycat program
for example you were saying that the
categories were defined a priory and the
same thing with
francois schwalle's arc challenge
there's this notion that core knowledge
must be something which is pre-defined
do you think that's the case or should
it be something which is
changing all the time
yeah that's a that's a open question i
think uh
you know there's this notion of core
knowledge that was i think first
proposed by uh
elizabeth stelke who's a developmental
psychologist who said
what what do we base all of our concepts
on it's the
system of what she called core knowledge
which has to do with
objects and their interactions
and spatial concepts
uh some social concepts like you know i
can recognize
that you have agency you you are
different from
say the table you're sitting in front of
because you're going to affect things
and some other sort of really basic
ideas that
that she was proposing that babies are
sort of innately
using to as a scaffolding for all other
concepts
whether that's true or not i think it's
still you know an open research
question um there there have been a lot
of efforts
in the past in ai to try to try and come
up with these primitives
like if you say like transitivity you
know there was a work by
uh roger shank of yale where he
developed this whole
language called um conceptual dependency
i think
that was all situations could be
described in terms of this language
it didn't really work out very well
because
um i don't it's hard to
boil down everything we know into
this set of primitives i think in a kind
of operational way
that you can implement it in a machine
so i
i think that that's still an open
question and one of the things that i
strongly believe is that ai needs to
really look
very carefully at cognitive science
and things like developmental psychology
and if i think there's an interaction
there that really
is going to be quite beneficial and you
know we're seeing that with a lot of
different research projects people are
engaging in right now
so yeah there's a lot of open questions
in cognition
in the science of intelligence that
we're going to have to solve i think
before we can
build ai systems that can be this kind
of
flexible common sense agents like we are
yeah we spoke with a professor of
cognitive computing j
mark bishop some weeks back and you know
to your point number four
even if there is some innate knowledge
it seems like much more
knowledge is really external or
externally learned and he made the point
that look
intelligence is implemented by neurons
in a brain a brain and a body a body in
a society a society in an environment
environments in a world and it's that
entire system that leads to this
emergent
knowledge base and learning you know
process
concepts that are being created and you
know to your point too about
if we try to manually distill all that
into a set of core concepts then we're
gonna run into the same kinds of
problems that
yan lacoon has pointed out so many times
that well you're going to get them wrong
or they're going to be incomplete
and so you've really got to learn them
but it has to be learned from a much
more complex system than just
the artifacts that people produce like
all our text on the internet for example
yeah and it's surprising i mean i agree
with you but it's surprising how
controversial that is
that this whole notion of the extended
mind
you say or embodiment or the necessity
of interacting in this real environment
instead of a sort of a
artifact like the internet but that's
it's still not generally accepted that
we're gonna need that
to build generally intelligent systems
um
so i think that's that's still an
argument that's been going on for
many many years and we'll see we'll see
how it plays out
as far as i understood and i agree with
you you we have to
take a lot of inspiration from our
intelligence to build
the artificial intelligences and
understood so far from your work that
you explain uh very clearly that
artificial intelligences we have so
far are no human intelligences how do
you think about
human intelligence is now in in in
isolation
like do you think we are
the only way possible to get
to intelligence or do you think we're
more of an
accident and we could arrive at the
same kind of solution in a different way
and perhaps
are we seeing intelligence but not
recognizing it
that's a great question i you know i
i don't know the answer i think it's
very possible that there's other ways to
get to intelligence
um that we are there's a lot of
what biologists would call historical
contingency
that underlies the evolution of human
intelligence
and uh it's not clear at all but that's
the only way
uh there so the question is you know are
we is there a different kind of
intelligence
maybe maybe some of these ai systems
actually have an intelligence that we're
not recognizing
sure i you know the term intelligence is
not very well defined so we'd have to
do a better job of defining it but
you know people often ask me why why
focus on human intelligence why not just
why not have kind of a different kind of
intelligence that's machine intelligence
and i guess there's a couple of answers
one is absolutely
so for instance this latest um
breakthrough if you will by
uh deep mind on protein folding it's
very
un it's not human like it's not the way
that humans would go about
figuring out uh this scientific problem
and that's great that's like a very
great complement to humans i've heard
many times that people talk about
alphago
coming up with these um
plays and go that are just very unhuman
like no human ever would have thought of
them and yet they're
they're brilliant humans can recognize
that they're they're brilliant
only after the fact so i think that kind
of
different kind of intelligence can
complement
our intelligence in certain domains but
in domains where
the machines have to interact with us
in the real world like self-driving cars
we don't want them to be generalizing in
a different way than we do because then
we'll get into accidents and that's
we've seen that happen where uh
self-driving cars sort of
perceive very differently than we do
and they perceive like for instance that
um a picture of a stop sign on the back
of a truck
is an actual stop sign and slam on the
brakes and cause an accident
you know that's just one example so i
think it's very dependent you know we
need machines that think like us
that are that have the kind of human
generalizations we make
when we're interacting with them and
in this uh in the real world in in
everyday sense but in other cases we
want them to have
very complementary kinds of intelligence
right
that's kind of a complex answer no it
makes sense another thing too is that
of course there are some of these
historical accidental aspects to our
intelligence but
100 percent of our intelligence is not a
historical accident and sometimes the
fact that there is
any accident is used kind of as a really
just an excuse to ignore
all the rest of how human cognition is
implemented and yet it is the only
example of general intelligence that we
have
we should highly value the billion years
of
evolution that went into into producing
it and so there there has to be more we
can learn
than just the single artificial neuron
that we've learned so far
can i just push back another tiny bit
because um to leticia's point as well
just because we have an example we have
an existence proof of intelligence it
doesn't necessarily mean that it
couldn't be
improved upon the feature of our
intelligence as melanie
talks about a lot is you know our
ability to create these beautiful
conceptual analogies
but also if you look at the alpha fold
program it has some
really cool things built into it like
for example the ability to
um recognize symmetry and invariants in
data you know francois chile talks about
the kaleidoscope effect and
most of the information in the universe
is actually the same thing just
represented in slightly different ways
so there's no reason why in principle we
couldn't add those two things together
and get an even better intelligence
the intelligence we have was
evolved with very real biological
limitations
well no i don't i don't think anybody
would disagree with that and i'll let
melanie speak that i think the point i
was making is that
i don't think we captured all the useful
all the utility of human intelligence in
1958 when we created the perceptron
and and just tweaked its kind of
activation functions you know since then
i think for example like you brought up
jeff hawkins i think a lot of things he
talks about about looking at sort of the
the sparsity of biological networks and
how maybe we need to do
more with smaller but more sophisticated
networks i just think there's a
tremendous amount more
we should learn and not kind of throw
the baby out with the bathwater to use
an analogy
yeah uh yeah i think
i i think there's quite a bit more we
can learn from
our own uh intelligence from
neuroscience from
psychology uh and in fact those fields
are still quite incomplete so they don't
want anymore they can learn uh
uh but they're they're
as you as tim said that you know there
are things about us
that perhaps aren't optimal in some
sense or they're they're optimal for our
our particular biological niche but uh
maybe not for the world we live in with
the world we're creating
uh we see a lot of our cognitive biases
are
hurting us so perhaps
machines can help us kind of escape from
those biases
however you know i this is a debate i've
had with
many different people that there's this
notion that
you can kind of have it all in a machine
you can have
perfect reasoning and
creativity and all the good things about
our intelligence without any of the bad
things
without any of the biases sort of pure
intelligence and i'm not convinced at
all that that's
possible people like uh you know stuart
russell
kind of feel that you can build this
super intelligent
systems without any of our biases
or sort of common sense
and therefore they pose risks
but i'm not convinced that we can
separate these things so easily
could i touch on next we did actually
have a question lined up on pure
intelligence so i should ask that now
we spoke to jeff hawkins last week i'm
sure you're aware of his work and
he thinks that if only we modeled the
general learning algorithm of the
neocortex
with the you know without the neuroses
of the primitive monkey brain that we
have underneath
that we could create a utopian and pure
form of intelligence one which wouldn't
want to kill us and
one which wouldn't suffer itself if we
if we turned it off and um
analogously go fi people think that we
should forget about the brain entirely
and
implement the mind directly using a
typical programming language
um you know that simple computational
primitives can be composed together to
create
a pure although still possibly emergent
intelligence
do you think there's there's any
anything there at all
i think we don't understand enough about
intelligence to really
say that that such a thing would be
possible there's absolutely no
evidence in my mind that you could do
this that kind of separation
that those the constraints you know that
you have all these
that you can kind of skim off this
perfect intelligence
i think a lot of our intelligence
comes from our embeddedness in a social
world
we're extremely social species a lot of
things that we
consider to be sort of pure reasoning
are really actually
the tools we use in
in the um goal of improving our social
standing or
you know there's all kinds of
uh reasons that we do the things that we
do and i'm not sure you can separate
out this sort of pure intelligence this
you know what newell and simon
call this physical symbol system of
intelligence that doesn't rely on
the brain or if you're you know talking
to jeff hawkins
the the sort of primitive uh parts of
the brain
or uh the body or the embeddedness of
the body in the world
so that's my stance you know i don't
think anybody knows the answer just
because we don't understand these things
well enough
one reason but i have to really think
more about that but
one reason why i don't think this
absolute
awesome bias-less intelligence is
possible
is perhaps the second law of
thermodynamics
so i'm always i'm always surprised about
the
surprise in the community when it comes
to adversarial examples and unrobust
features and so on
because you know physics teaches us that
natural things like to minimize energy
they
like to go the easy the short in other
words the lazy way so
um what i don't understand why should
these
uh you know poor networks that we have
right now invest the energy and
you know go this extra mile to learn the
robust features or the features
we want and we think are right when
everything we do
is to give it a limited data set with a
limited objective function
um so my question is
could we humans ever define
or have an expectancy about the right
features aren't we um you know
making ai dirty just by the fact that we
are programming it and we are
making it serve us or make it useful for
us
uh yeah i think that's that's
possible that we you know we're giving
it the goals
the goal we're saying you know learn
learn this particular task uh
here's some data to learn it from
go go go for it you know
minimize your loss function that
is a that is that's the you know calling
that learning
is another one of these wishful
mnemonics i think that that learning in
humans and other animals is just very
different from that it's not
it's not this passive absorption of
of examples
labeled you know or not um that
it's much more active it's more social
it's more
um contextual
it's more self-motivated and
we learn in a very complex world so
i think all of those things are very
different from what machine learning is
all about
and machine learning is just set up to
as you say
just learn whatever the easiest path is
towards
minimizing the the objective the loss
function
given the data and that will lead to
shortcuts that are not robust
i wanted to ask you melanie in in your
opinion
when does a system do abstraction now um
we kind of need a test that this is
happening and it might sound like a
trivial question because i know you
could just say well it's the information
conversion ratio or the ability to deal
with novelty
but having been inspired by your writing
and also hof status surfaces and
essences
yeah we also wrote a paper called the
core of cognition which we'll talk about
in a sec but
um i watched a video by hofstatter
actually he said that
analogies were a bit like the interstate
freeway of the brain
which i thought was wonderful but could
you add a bit more flavor to
what exactly you mean by abstraction
yeah so so abstraction i think of it is
kind of a continuum
so i
you know we talk about classification or
categorization that that's kind of a
form of abstraction when i see
two examples of a category
like you know um
uh i i i
see two two different dogs and then i
categorize
the whole thing as dog i'm kind of
making an abstraction
moving away from the details of a
specific
instance but you can abstract even
further you know
in my paper i use the example of a
bridge you know said we think about
bridges the
the golden gate bridge or the brooklyn
bridge and
um but we ex we can
abstract that into um things like
a bridge of bridging the gender gap
or uh joe biden said he was a bridge
to a new generation of leaders and you
know we say these kinds of things all
the time we use them more metaphorically
but we don't even notice that it's a
metaphor because
concepts are sort of on this continuum
of being extremely
concrete and individualistic to
being more and more abstract and
metaphorical
so i think of it as kind of a continuum
and that's really i
what makes us so flexible is our ability
to kind of move
so fluidly along this continuum exactly
and that's why
in a way i feel that there's something
special about the structure of the human
brain
again jeff hawkins was talking about um
reference frames essentially but so we
when we're thinking we're traversing
reference frames and we have a very
associative brain and in the core of
cognition paper um hostato was talking
about the word
shadow um it's a it's a really
interesting word isn't it because you
could say i'm in the shadow of my mother
or um a tree shadow if the snow fell on
the tree and underneath the tree was was
a shadow
so um yeah he says it's a blurry region
in semantic space
as there's any human category because
the subtleties of mapping situations
onto other situations
the very human faculty of analogy making
he says
is that you know the concept is a
package of of analogies
so his core idea of the apparatus of
thinking is that
um it's a series of leaps involving
high-level perception
activation of concepts and long-term
memory transfer to short-term memory and
then partial and context-dependent
unpacking of chunks and then further
high-level perception and he says that
his ideas are significantly different
from pure
associatism uh which i suppose you would
say jeff hawkins is a fan of that
and and his focus is on the transport
between the long-term memory and the
short-term memory and how it's
unpacked and processed so the thing is
as you were saying before
cognitive scientists have some really
interesting and divergent ideas about
what cognition really is and when we
spoke to gary marcus the other week he
had a
another you know another different view
on it um we don't really seem to be
having this conversation with cognitive
scientists at all in the ai world do it
i think it's it it's happening more and
more
so when i went into ai and
i started graduate school in the mid-80s
uh
there was a lot of interaction there was
this notion that cognitive science was
bringing together people from different
fields including ai that ai was a core
part of cognitive science ai in the 90s
i mean became machine learning
essentially
and be went off in this direction more
statistics and statistical learning and
further away from cognitive sciences
but i think now people are realizing the
limitations of these
purely statistical approaches and a lot
of people are now coming back to
thinking about
intersections with cognitive science uh
even
you know the the pioneers of deep
learning like
yosho avengio thinking a lot about
the ideas from from psychology and
uh you know i ideas from uh say
daniel kahneman benjio talks a lot about
system one system two
etc uh so
there's more and more interaction which
is a good thing uh
i think uh there's
it's still at the forefront of research
is trying to incorporate a lot of these
ideas from cognitive science
into a.i and you know even like people
like francois chalet who you talk to
talks a lot about developmental
psychology and ideas from
people like stelke and and others about
core knowledge so that that's a good
thing
right so i i'm i'm optimistic now
about sort of making new progress in the
field yeah i mean just as a quick
follow-up i think you're right actually
gary marcus said that
yoshio benjio basically introduces his
talks now with some of the stuff that he
was saying two years ago and
and as you say that the recognition from
yandere kun that
common sense knowledge is the dark
matter of the universe and as you say
that the spell key work as well
cited by charles so maybe you're right
actually maybe there has been a real
move in that direction
and apart from cognitive science you
have been in this field for a long time
i think that's
the most awesome thing when somebody
as young as me speaks to you what are
the things
back then that you as a field knew
better
when doing research and what are the
things
you forgot that were good and also the
other way around what are the cool
things we have now that
weren't there back then
yeah well okay so
you know what back then of course
people i think were more
in a way more open-minded about what
approaches were
worth following i felt i feel like the
field was more diverse you know right
now
ai the field only has a a small number
of sort of top-tier
conference venues that people go to and
they're all
really very much focused on deep
learning
um very it's not easy to
uh publish on other kinds of approaches
and these venues
uh the fields kind kind of lost
diversity in in ideas you know
not to mention other kinds of diversity
but um
i i i feel like that that's something
that
a lot of people are saying uh we need
more new ideas we need
more maybe some ideas that people were
actually investigating
20 years ago maybe should be coming back
so you know one of those ideas i've
worked on a few different areas like
my work with hofstetter on analogy i
think that's something that
could is poised for a comeback also
people are now paying more attention to
things like evolutionary
computations or ideas from evolution and
instead of just this
deep neural networks so i do think
there's going to be a lot more
diversity coming into the field as more
and more people realize that there are
limitations of the current
set of approaches and how long would you
estimate
that it will take until people wake up
or do you see already that people are
waking up i guess so right
oh yeah absolutely i see people are
waking up you know
for example i saw a job ad
for the google brain team
for somebody in like
artificial life genetic algorithms
uh these kind you know cellular automata
these kinds of ideas that
we haven't seen in in like these big
companies that are doing research at ai
that that they're kind of opening up to
people
outside the field of deep learning which
is which is a promising thing
so i think it's good it's happening
already
so um melanie i wanted to ask you about
the
nature of knowledge representation and
why exactly go phi was seen as brittle
so um i feel that you got pretty close
to the center of the bullseye in your
book
when you said that most of the common
sense knowledge that we have is
experiential
ineffable multi-modal and not accessible
in any structured form anywhere on the
internet
and go fi people would argue blind that
knowledge about the world like
facts and events and mathematics et
cetera is absolute as we were saying
before
you know it would exist um you know in
some cases even if the universe didn't
exist and um they think that knowledge
must be acquired not learned and can
only be succinctly described using
symbols and relations which in plain
language means something
a bit like a mind map or a network
diagram but intuitively much of the
um other experiential common sense core
knowledge we possess cannot be described
in this way you know a lot of our
sensory everyday
knowledge now um go five people also
cite marvin minsky's society of mind
where he projects an apparently brittle
modular architecture of the mind
disregarding the strong associativity
and compositionality of our own brains
and you said in your book that the deep
learning driven computer vision boom has
apparently stalled a bit recently some
years after the heady highs of
alex krachewski's imagenet moment in
2012 the performance on harder
challenges like object recognition
weren't quite as successful and the
realization has set in
that visual intelligence is not easily
separable from the rest of intelligence
especially
general knowledge abstraction and
language
yeah i mean i i think that says it all
that
this idea that we we have a visual you
know
visual intelligence language
intelligence et cetera it's it i think
is
an artificial separation that you can
actually um
say separate our ability to to
understand language from our ability to
make sense of visual or other sensory
data
and uh that's something that
people in it certainly in gofi
felt we could do but we still see it um
and i think you know if you ask people
in the field they sort of agree
they'll agree yes absolutely but but
it's hard to figure out what to do about
it you know
how do we do how do we even start
um so i think that you know that
there there's this interesting program
now
at darpa which is uh you know
one of the bigger funders of ai in the
us
on called uh foundations of machine
common sense where where they're
bringing together ai people with with
developmental psychologists to kind of
try and recapitulate development
between zero and 18 months for human
infants
to say that that's really that's kind of
the key is to figure out
how babies actually acquire the
knowledge that they need
to to scaffold everything else
um whether that will succeed i don't
know but it's
it's a it's an interesting approach
so i you mentioned earlier the analogy
um
analogy work that you did say like the
copycat for example
and i was i was reading over those
papers again recently in prep for this
and what i loved was in the in the very
beginning of say that the chapter 5
work that you did in the 1995 book it
says something like this is not
connectionist it's not symbolic uh it's
somewhere in between maybe some people
would call that hybrid that we didn't
set out to build
a hybrid system what i'm wondering is is
today
say you know more than 20 years later if
you've kind of
thought about that again in the context
of what's happening right now with
transformers and attention because
your work there had kind of an attention
mechanism you know there would be these
um concepts and
the different agents could pay attention
to more or the other and there was an
offsetting uh you know happiness factor
that tried to
kind of rein in the attention mechanism
i'm wondering like where you think
some of the ideas at least that were in
copycat where they stand in relation to
what's around today either with
transformers or omniglot or dreamcoder
and what you think would be some really
promising ideas to salvage and maybe
refine a bit
to reuse now
so one of the big differences with
things like
transformers and i think neural nets in
general
is the idea of dynamics that that
perception is this dynamical
unfolding of a process that occurs in
time
with feedback you know at every step
continual feedback so when we were
looking
at analogy and and what hofstadter
called high level perception which means
sort of
looking at a situation and applying the
concepts that we have to that particular
situation whether it be
in the mind's eye or a real situation um
that happened over time and that there
were agents that would
interact with each other in its temporal
way
transformers in fact are the opposite of
that
transformers and the attention mechanism
for that
is kind of a way to take away the the
the idea of temporal feedback and do
everything all at once you know it's
like
transformers uh
were were a way to get deal with sort of
long-range dependencies and data without
having to do sort of this recurrence
recurrent uh processing that you would
get like in that lstm
or something like that and it showed you
could do it without all that recurrence
which is convenient but i think it
misses
the whole dynamics of perception
so that's that's one of the main
differences that um
i see and even the recurrent neural
networks
don't you know are only very
mildly recurrent right
and i think you know one thing that we
see
in the human brain and other mammals is
that like there's a huge amount of
feedback
and there's a very important aspect of
temporal feedback over a period you know
maybe milliseconds
perception but it's like some a lot of
stuff that's happening
that you can't capture in a
sort of static um static system that
looks at all the data at once
right and we've we've kind of made that
point several times on the show which is
that
no matter how you spin it you know
almost all
of the neural networks that people work
on today are equivalent to
a fixed depth unrolled you know network
of some kind
and so they completely lack this
iterative open-ended kind of capability
to compute
really and if you try to add that in
they become
impossible to optimize it's like now we
can no longer learn because now we have
this open-ended
sort of iteration and you know somebody
was challenging well yeah but
we can just make them really really deep
and and then it'll be okay and i said
well i mean imagine andrew weil and his
addict trying to figure out fermat's
last theorem like
how many iterations did he need to go
through kind of computationally in order
to achieve that and so what you're
saying is that
that dynamic process really that the
computational
temporal iteration is what's missing
it's one of the big missing components
of deep learning today um i think that's
fair and if that is the case what do you
think the most promising approach for
trying to fold that back into
deep learning if possible might be
i'm not sure you can fold it into deep
learning um
i mean whatever you know deep learning
is a term that
changes its meaning all the time but uh
i think it's possible that that
something like
the neural network could be part of a
overall
architecture that has this kind of
temporal dynamic quality
i you mentioned uh
i think you mentioned dreamcoder uh
which is a system i
i'm familiar with uh which is a very
different approach
it's using uh what it's called
probabilistic
program induction that is trying to
given an input trying to generate a
program a computer program in some
language that can um
sort of uh conceptualize the input
like you say omniglot which was a set of
uh
handwritten uh characters in different
languages uh
trying to conceptualize to abstract them
but that again uh if
that was not a system that
had a particular input and had this sort
of dynamic
iterative feedback uh perceptual
approach to making sense of the system
it was more like
let's search the possibility of all
programs that
in some intelligent way but um
so i think these all these systems are
have
some useful ideas in them
uh but but we haven't figured out yet
how to take all of the
the parts and put them together in some
coherent
architecture and that that's something
that you know we tried to do with the
copycat program but
it had a lot of limitations it didn't
learn and
it was only you know it had a very
limited
sort of micro world that it was working
so one of the things i'm working on is
how do we sort of extend all that
those ideas yeah i mean on the subject
of having these
because i know again you said in your
book melanie that the brain has many
more feedback connections than feed
forward connections even though we don't
entirely understand
why and when we spoke to jeff hawkins
and nimenter they are one of the only
companies that were genuinely trying to
do this they created an htm algorithm
and they
they actually created this kind of
cyclical processing and
there are some um you know biologically
inspired approaches to neural networks
modeling the temporal binding circuits
the temporal dynamics and so on but
the problem is i mean even then let's
say that you could do this maybe some
magic will emerge and
we'll get to emergence later but the
problem is you
you lose the computational advantage of
having these deep learning models
because if they are just monolithic
matrices and you can just do stochastic
gradient descent and you can parallelize
it
um all sorts of magic happens but if you
directly implement the kind of feedback
mechanism that we're talking about
it's just as intractable as doing the
discrete program search that
tannenbaum's group is doing
sure that's that's absolutely right and
and
that's that's like the big problem how
how do you do this in a tractable way so
this is where
sort of the symbolic ai comes in because
using symbols as opposed to say neurons
uh it enables
the system to be more tractable but it
also cut
you know comes with this brittleness so
you really need to
figure out how to kind of get these
emergent
symbols that
do make the computation more tractable
without having to um uh
without but but still maintaining the
the
sort of flexibility of this more
sub symbolic architecture
and yeah no one knows how to do that
that's that's the big problem
what are your thoughts on the
neurosymbolic camp
of of folks and what they're up to any
promise there
yeah that so that's i you know that's a
lot of dif
that's an umbrella term for a lot of
different efforts
i think that there's some interesting
ideas there you know dream coder itself
was a neurosymbolic
system in that it had symbolic aspect
which was the program induction but it
also had the neuro
aspect which was the sort of search
using neural networks to assist in
search
sort of in a similar way to what uh say
alphago does where uh there's this kind
of symbolic
structure of tree search and the neural
network helps in figuring out
how to sort of intelligently or use
intuition to search the tree
uh so i i think that's that's a you know
interesting idea and i've actually
thought about how to
incorporate something like neural
networks
in this sort of copycat like
architecture
and we built a system that just did a
little bit of that
for visual analogies um
but it's still you know it's it's how to
do that in a tractable way it is still
still a challenge because i'm a little
bit allergic
to this kind of hybrid
notation because let's say a graph
neural network is still very much a
connectionist model it's
a it's projecting some kind of dis let's
say topology into a vector space and
something like dreamcoder is still very
much discreet first
so i mean copycat for example that was a
really interesting combination wasn't it
it was kind of discreet first but then
you had these connection weights
right between the letters a little bit
like a you know like an adjacency matrix
or something so would you describe that
as a
connectionist model presumably not
yeah i don't you know it didn't really
fit into any existing category because
it
used a very symbolic kind of semantic
network if you will
of concepts uh that
but that were applied in a much
a kind of a using continuous
probabilities and and and a lot
lots of sort of more continuous value
aspects to it so i would say copycat was
i you know it's hard to judge but it was
more symbolic than connectionist but it
had elements of both and it had elements
of probabilistic reasoning as well
uh so i don't know it wasn't it wasn't
easy to to categorize i don't know if
you'd call it a
neurosymbolic or hybrid or whatever so
yeah so that was one of the problems it
was hard to people would ask you know
submit papers to conferences like what
what is this is it
connectionist is it symbolic is it go
fine
well not really none of the above you
need a new word it's going to be a
franken ai or something like that yeah
exactly
yeah i'm just i'm not sure if it's
composable because if you do project
symbols into a vector space it's
irreversible and it's undecidable and
you seem to
lose the benefits that you did have
before with the symbols
but um can we get to emergence quickly
so um
language and consciousness seem to be
emergent society money and politics
seem to be emergent simple rules like in
conway's
game of life can produce incredible
emergent behavior
and you remember before we were saying
that go-fi people implement the mind and
connectionists implement the brain
so there's there's like a ladder of um
emergence isn't there and do you have
any view
on because i i guess maybe the higher up
in the ladder
you implement something the more
complexity there is
but there seems to be more concreteness
to the implementation so do you have any
views on where in the ladder we should
be implementing ai
oh so there's a lot of
things to unpack there so i'm not sure
yeah there's there's a strict ladder
here
so uh
i guess what you're asking is you know
we have sort of symbolic ai which
ignores everything
all the levels below like neurons or
neural assemblies or all the structures
that
jeff hawkins might consider essential
and then there's kind of the
intermediate things like connectionists
you know i wouldn't say they implement
the brain
exactly but they they implement some
something that's uh
maybe a little more a little more
brain-like
but connection is you know whatever
those
nodes happen to be they can represent
con you know symbolic concepts uh we saw
that a lot in connectionism
then there's like vector like
deep learning today which everything's
embedded in these
high dimensional vectors um where you
can't really interpret them very well
so you're sort of saying like where
where should we be on that
kind of spectrum yeah i mean i could ask
a follow-up question which i which i
think adds a bit of flavor as well but i
think a lot of this comes down to
again it's levels of abstraction of
computational representation
so go fi people there are professors
like uh krishnaswamy who think that
symbols and functions and relations are
the universal primitives of computation
and then
there are people like scott aronson who
think that computation is much lower
level than that
and this debate can be summed up as the
theory of programming
versus the theory of computation there's
actually a great article on it that i
can link in the
description but there does seem to be
something really important here because
in your europe's talk and chalets
ii for that matter you are speaking
about program synthesis and what chalet
calls type two extrapolation
and there seems to be an acknowledgement
that we need to have type one
extrapolation
using um some lower level computational
primitives so it might be a neural
network for example but in both regimes
the code would soon become
completely opaque to human understanding
so which computational primitive or
primitive should we be using to build ai
should it be type one or
or type two or should they be enmeshed
together as chole argued for
and perhaps it is possible to implement
a mind
in python but would any human understand
the code
oh hey probably not
uh you know although the code if it was
a mine
the code would be able to explain itself
in the way that we
explain our thoughts and those
explanations would be flawed
because it wouldn't have insight into
what you know
how its mind is actually operating
so i think um there may be some
you know general trade-off laws of
trade-off between
uh explanation and the ability to
understand
the code and it's sort of expressiveness
you know we can look and that doesn't
mean the code has to be
complex necessarily because you point
out like the game of life
incredibly simple code and yet it can
give rise to arbitrarily complex
structures
um and i think the same is true for our
brains probably
there's some relatively simple
quote-unquote code underlying this but
it's
out of this simple code can emerge a lot
of complexity
you know so i don't know the answer i
think that's
it's a hard question you know and even a
lot of people would say the questions
just
even just wrong-headed because you're
talking about
computational primitives and maybe
computation itself is just the wrong
metaphor to think about how how the
brain or the mind works
and that's you know it's it's a metaphor
it's not
it's it it like anything else in in in
our discussion of the brain
we use all these metaphors that guide us
in certain ways and
for the last you know uh
i don't know 70 years or so we've used
computation
and we said the brain is a computer
and that leads us to think about things
like representations
and memory
and other kinds of computer like things
that um
maybe is the wrong way to think about it
i think you're absolutely right actually
because we had professor mark bishop on
and he and his thesis
is that computationalism is wrong
because it would
i don't want to get into the details of
his argument but it would imply that
there were
an infinitude of conscious experiences
um
you know even in even in the shirt that
i'm that i'm wearing i suppose it would
lead to pan psychism but
can i ask a fun just i just got one fun
question about because earlier
i didn't get that my internet was gone
when we were talking about the
adversarial examples but
you know in in the uh book that that has
edited uh mind's eye
which i really enjoyed mind's eye one of
my favorite short stories in there is
the riddle of the universe and its
solution
and essentially it was about an
adversarial example for the human mind
where there was something that when
displayed on a computer screen would
cause the human mind to just crash
and anybody who saw that would crash and
so it starts off with a grad student
crashes and is stuck at the computer for
days and
and then the people responding to it
they crash and eventually it
it becomes known like what's happening
but nobody can look at the screen
because they'll crash
and i just you know i thought that was
kind of a funny example
you know but the human mind so far
doesn't really seem to be that
vulnerable to uh
to those kinds of adversarial examples
at least not to crash but we certainly
fall for them
in other contexts right like various
illusions and things like that
i wonder if you just see any connection
there between what
machine learned systems do in the human
mind
yeah that reminds me of the monty python
episode
the funniest joke ever that that like
people it's so funny that people it's
like people just fall down laughing and
you use it as a weapon in war
and the soldiers on the other side
wearing like earplugs so they can't hear
him
but um but yeah so so
so adversarial examples are
you know you could say kind of
metaphorically there's adversarial
examples for
for humans and illusions or
our cognitive biases kind of make us
vulnerable to adversarial examples and
things like advertisers take advantage
of that
to kind of manipulate us that um
we're very easily manipulable
manipulatable
uh those are a little bit different in
uh quality from the kinds of adversarial
examples that
full machines because those are
examples that would never fool a human
uh like
you know looking at a school bus
changing a few pixels and then
thinking that it's an ostrich but um
sure any i think any kind of intelligent
system is probably going to be
vulnerable to some kind of adversarial
examples that's probably some
provable thing somehow that you know
there's no
way to build a system an intelligent
system that
isn't vulnerable to some something like
that
um but the the the adversarial examples
of full machines really show
what they show to me is that they're not
using the same kinds of
features to make decisions that we use
they're using something else and that's
something that's important for how we
think about their
reliability general and so on
i mean this gets us on to the shortcut
rule actually because um
in your europe's talk you spoke about
raven's progressive matrices
and the idea that they're highly
correlated with human intelligence
and there have been several papers
recently applying them uh applying deep
learning to them but you pointed out
that one particular paper there was
a bias on the way that the um the
matrices were
were projected and when the bias was
removed the performance fell
right down and was nowhere anywhere near
as good as human performance
but even without the bias though there
might have been other potential
statistical shortcuts
and guillain lampel's work springs to
mind because he did this
symbolic integration paper and that
seemed to do very well as well but
there's always the question with deep
learning that you know my goodness is it
just learning some statistical
regularities and it's not really doing
it the way we want to do it
and then we have a whole field of
interpretable machine learning but it
turns out that that's not particularly
good at helping us understand
how deep learning models work either
because in various ways they might
linearize or give us a kind of a looking
glass into one
aspect of the neural network but not be
particularly salient in helping us
understand
and um you know charlay mentioned the
shortcut rule in his talk didn't he but
it's it's essentially this
thing that the neural network doesn't do
it the way that we want it to do it or
the way that humans would do it in
respect of the same task and
you said as well that um eric horvids
you know the microsoft research
director he said that deep learning is a
bit like alchemy i don't really know
what we can do to fix this problem do
you have any ideas
right so so one of the problems i think
is that machine learning systems today
rely on
large numbers of examples
so it's possible to learn these
statistical kind of shortcuts
even in it because any you know it's
it's i think it's impossible to get rid
of statistical shortcuts and they need
data set they're always going to be
there uh
but if you rely on what people call few
shot learning
you can't learn them it's just not
possible because you don't have enough
examples
but today's neural networks uh like rely
on these
uh large numbers of examples so the
ravens problem for example
people what these are like these little
iq tests
visual problems where a human
isn't trained specifically to do these
problems
we cut you know our training is life we
live in the world we
learn to abstract and then we we're
given these little tests
to test our abstraction abilities
whereas
the the paradigms in machine learning is
that
they they generate automatically
thousands or tens or hundreds of
thousands of these problems
then train the machine on a large number
of them
and that the problem with that is then
the machine can learn shortcuts
but if you do it the way that humans are
you just show them a few examples
they can't learn shortcuts and that i
think that was one of the the
motivations for chalet's uh
arc uh corpus his abstraction and
reasoning corpus
was really few shot learning that
i'll give you three examples now you
solve the the
a similar problem so you can you can't
learn shortcuts you have to learn
the concept that that that's the sort of
abstract concept there so i think that's
one of the main problems
another problem that that's more of like
the way we measure the systems is that
we tend to
to rely on measures of accuracy how many
did it get right
well that's not a very good measure if
there's a shortcut because you know
your test set that you're evaluating on
has the same statistical
uh correlations as your training set
so the accuracy doesn't measure really
the generalization so we have to come up
with better metrics of robustness and
generality and so forth
so that's that's my thought on that
although you did say on the arc
challenge that the winning solution
didn't actually generalize very well to
other
problems and it's it's quite a simple
domain
the winning solution only got like 20
20 20 or 25 right so it's you know to
really general and i i
you know it's possible the arc challenge
uh has we don't want we shouldn't
measure only on accuracy which is what
that
measure was that the arc challenge needs
some better metrics
of success yeah and i think we're a
little in a contradictory
position where we expect or we
want the models to have the features
in the same way as we do but we also
want super
human intelligence to be able to do
things we cannot do and to do superhuman
things they have to have also superhuman
features
and um i'm a little undecided whether
we're calling
things like shortcuts and um you know
we say it's the model is cheating us
because it's not doing what we wanted to
do
what if we're not a little unfair
against the model
and what i'm interested in asking is
whether
so if you if i give you a mod that
solves anything you want i give you a
self-driving car
and you know that that car because i
tell you
look those features that that ai is
using
are not human-like at all but that
self-driving car
is absolutely super robust it's giving
you 100
accuracy on everything you wanted it
doesn't crash
but you know it's not solving the task
for the right
reasons would you try harder to make it
uh solve the task for the right reasons
or would you leave it at that
so i think that that's the situation we
are in now that that that
you know these so self-driving cars do
well on their
evaluations they can recognize stop
signs
yield signs and speed limit signs just
fine on their evaluations but then they
run into these
weird new situations that weren't that
are like
out of their training distribution if
you will and they fail because
they were never evaluated on that kind
of thing um
so i guess the question is when you say
100 right
for the wrong reasons how do we know
that that's going to generalize
uh and this is i think something that
does say that the
autonomous vehicle uh industries
grappling with how you know
how do you how do you do quality control
how do you do verification for these
systems that are based on deep learning
um how do you know
how they're going to perform in new
situations
so if they're doing if they're doing
their task they're making decisions with
the sort of the wrong
features they're probably not going to
be able to generalize
as well as we do in all cases and
everything that they're going to
encounter
but do we generalize well
i mean humans do dumb things all the
time like mistake the gas pedal for the
for the brake pedal yeah so humans are
not great drivers as we all know
um but they're not great drivers for
different reasons
than uh self-driving cars and so
that's you know you might say well
and people do say like well humans are
terrible they get into all kinds of
accidents so we should trust these
systems they're going to save lives
but it's hard to trust them if we don't
understand how they're making their
decisions right
so it's and that's the same thing in
like medical applications okay
if we don't understand how they're
making their decisions how can we really
trust them
it seems like self-driving the
self-driving problem is sort of like the
patrick wins i think he's
said it was winskin or minsky with the
computer vision all over again which is
you know
elon musk has finally admitted
self-driving cars is a hard problem you
know this was over a different time
scale than the little vision
activity right i
i thought it was amazing like right
after i uh
wrote my paper why ai is harder than we
think
elon musk came out with a on twitter
saying gee
self-driving is harder than we thought
[Laughter]
indeed i mean on the point about
the the errors that we make and maybe
i'm sure our neurons do make lots of
errors if you do believe as hawkins does
that our brain is
um a kind of you know lots of voting
between different prediction models
i think it's the strong multi-modality
and embodiment and interaction with our
environment that
creates the flexibility and robustness
so a lot of our
um real intelligence is emergent but
it's based on some very faulty
underpinnings but
my final question to you melanie is is
about the illusion of intelligence and
the impossibility of creating it
you said in your book that people were
convinced in the 1960s that solving
chess would require
real intelligence and then there's this
thing called the mccorduck effect which
is that every time we make a
breakthrough in artificial intelligence
there's a chorus of people that say
that's not really intelligence and
charlay in particular points out that
infinite prize and experience do not
and intelligence make i think that
humans have an aversion to intelligence
becoming transactional
and it being disentangled from feeling
and embodiment
and as a thought experiment imagine we
had a supercomputer that can compute
everything instantly right we could
simulate the entire universe and perform
a tree search through it
but it wouldn't actually be that simple
would it as hofstadter said what
constitutes a state
situations in the world don't come
nicely framed situations have no
boundaries
you don't know what's inside the
boundary and what's outside the boundary
uh professor carl fristen who he had on
the show he had a similar dilemma
which required him um to uh
you know use a rather vague concept of a
mathematic he called it a markov blanket
didn't he um in his formalism of an
intelligent agent
and you said in your book that andre
kirpathy acknowledged this when he said
that every single assumption which was
made by alphago
was violated in the real world so it's
really really difficult isn't isn't it
to create intelligence
yeah it's extremely difficult uh
i quoted in my book somebody a a
researcher who said that
you know if when asked how far are we
from
general a.i he said we're
100 nobel prizes away which uh
it's a way of saying that you know that
many
enormous discoveries so yeah it's not
like ai is
is um failing
it's that it's a really hard problem and
and ai's only been around for
you know less than 100 years i guess and
and
it's not surprising that we haven't
solved it yet because it's a really hard
problem you know we've got
i think a lot of this idea a lot of what
ai has done is made us appreciate how
hard intelligence is you know we
you know minsky had this idea back in
the 60s that
computer vision he could assign it to a
student
mit undergraduate over the summer and
they solved it basically
and then he said well it was harder than
we thought uh
that's kind of the the the trajectory
we've seen and things like
chess that we used to think maybe
required
full intelligence what we consider to be
full intelligence
it not only you know changed our idea of
success but it it changed our idea what
intelligence
is all about which we still are
grappling with
amazing uh professor melanie mitchell
it's been an absolute honor to have you
on the show thank you so much for
joining us here
well thanks thanks for inviting me it's
been a lot of fun okay so this is the um
this is the after show
debrief guys
what'd you think of uh that episode of
mlst
i really enjoyed it and i think we had a
wonderful guest really and
i can see that now mlst has a reputation
because
every time you're raising the bar with a
more interesting
guess that's really great it's quite
intimidating really to
be a co-host thanks for inviting me
i know like today we're we were talking
with an icon from a lineage of icons
now what um no it was amazing to have
melanie on because she's been such a
huge inspiration for me i've been
following her work for so long
and um she's one of these old-school
computer scientists um she's a really
rare breed actually
it's um it's an absolute honor to get
people like her on the show because
she's just got such a
long kind of time horizon to
contextualize a lot of her ideas
yeah and it's really great that she was
a
long time in the field because sometimes
i mean i'm so junior compared where
right
it's obvious but sometimes i feel that
we peach two
students of our time are living in a
very
uncomfortable position in this field
because
there's so much to read that i really
wonder
when should i even go to the old school
stuff
i didn't even finish reading
what was out last week and it's it's a
really hard balance to
to make therefore you know having this
show that
strikes you in the face like look you
have to
know about these topics and you had
professor mark bishop and
yeah i mean literally he was giving me a
reading list for the next 10 years
and that's great because in this you
know sea of papers
it's a really great pointer to the
interesting
questions and not to does a batch norm
work or not kind of questions but to the
most important
kind of questions well if i may offer
having been in your shoes
a long time ago if i may offer some some
humble advice
always make room for reading the origin
papers
you know or going back to when new ideas
were really coming about because
what's fascinating is you know they're
where they're developing their ideas
they're oftentimes presented
um you know barely very clearly from say
prior concepts that you may already be
familiar with and you can see the
development of the ideas
and then in some rare cases like and uh
and melanie's
1995 you know chapter five and hofstra's
book
is an example of this you go read it and
you think wow this is
i could be reading this today and a lot
of the language in there is still
relevant and they're very prescient
you know the same is true of a lot of
gary marcus's uh works or
organ lacoon or any of them for that
matter so i'd say always carve out a
little bit of time
you know maybe um 20 at least to go back
and
and every once in a while read some of
those older original papers it's worth
it
yeah it it's valuable advice
the comment i made at the beginning as
well i stand by
because i've i've read so much stuff now
to prepare for this show
and there's such an i'm really
interested in clear prose and clear
communication
i've even started listening to a great
podcast called the writing guy with
scott keyser
and you know he talks a lot about using
very concise language and preferring the
concrete to the abstract
and which ironically actually is is
saying don't use metaphors and analogies
but um i really noticed the difference
so with francois charley and gary marcus
and melanie mitchell
their writing is incredible and i put
myself back 10 years when
i felt very lost reading a lot of the
the literature on machine learning
it just felt overwhelming someone like
melanie comes along and
because she understands it deeply she's
she's consolidated her understanding and
she can give you very powerful
intuitions and she can
really give you the context about the
entire field and
i guess i'm just thinking if i could go
back in time if i was a little bit
smarter about
what i read online i think i would have
accelerated my learning quite a lot so
if you find yourself in the situation
where you just feel lost
probably you're just reading the wrong
material
it's hard it's just hard to filter it's
it's
you really need mentors for that i mean
having having great advisors and people
who can
they've done a lot of the filtering for
you and what's interesting about
melanie's writing is it was
great even when she was pretty much just
out of her
phd right even without this this
historical perspective she has so it's
just
you know you got to find good mentors in
your field that can guide you to
some of the best work uh otherwise it's
just overwhelming
yeah yeah and i think we're going a
little through a paradigm shift because
in term of mentoring because before you
if you wanted to study a certain topic
there were perhaps two people
in this world doing that so you had to
travel to let's say london to study
exactly that particular topic in
linguistics
and now it's uh it's more decentralized
now
for example let's suppose someone
doesn't have a mentor that
you know tells him what to read and what
to do but
he has the machine learnings we talked
about i i know i'm not there you know
but but that's that's the awesome thing
i because you're not completely lost
anymore
i mean in this sea of new information
that is getting out daily there's
also the counterbalance of pointers and
that's what i why i think youtubing is
great and i think
that's also reason why i'm doing it so
yeah fantastic
another thing as well is i love the
pragmatism of melanie and chile as well
the ability to contextualize
because in many ways as she made clear
there hasn't been any progress
since 1955 at that you know
kickoff in in dartmouth with uh minsky
and the other go-fi
pioneers there has been some incredible
achievements with deep learning and i
don't want to diminish
those achievements but as melanie said
after the
deepmind atari paper some other folks
came along with a really simple
evolutionary algorithm just randomly
setting some weights on a convolution on
your network and they beat the deep the
deep qn paper
so maybe it wasn't that intelligent
after all right and there's the same
yeah i'm sorry i didn't mean to talk
over you there's the same thing with the
uh
you know with the dota ai that was
playing uh defense of the ancients and
then people
very quickly figured out how to beat you
know the the ai
itself and so i think what's happening
here is just
it's really the the um exact thing she
said about minsky you know assigning the
computer vision to the
the uh mit intern for a summer project
or something it's just we've made
tremendous progress the problem is we
figured out that
that the goal post is like a lot further
away
than we than we thought it was so we
were looking at it and we thought it was
you know
just over the horizon but but actually
that was just a reflection
of a reflection from a different solar
system and we got
we got fooled really by kind of the
optical illusion there
yeah but all of the things that we find
easy are the hardest things in ai that's
what melanie said in her paper
and that's so true and all of the hype
is telling us that we're making this
incredible progress in ai but it's doing
things which are actually in fact
very easy for computers it's not i don't
think it's a fair comparison yeah
i kind of learned that as a kid because
i for a little while i was into rubik's
cubes right
like solving them on my own and then
learning the methods to solve them
and once you learn kind of the method to
solve a rubik's cube
for example if you give me a rubik's
cube i'm just always going to follow the
same method to solve it it doesn't
really matter
how mixed up it is even if you just
slightly mix it up like put two blocks
out of alignment
rather than try to figure out how to
specifically undo that i'm just going to
go through the procedure right
whereas for a computer if it's not
programmed to do that maybe it learned
how to do it through machine learning
it'll see the complexity differently
it's like oh only these two blocks are
messed up i have a little shortcut to do
that i don't need to go through the
whole procedure
whereas if it's very mixed up it has to
do more computation so i think it's just
pointing at how
humans and machines reason very
differently right now
and like melanie was saying kind of
towards at the end there it's it's
really been quite an educational process
for us
teaching us not only about machines and
how they learn but
inversely our efforts in machine
learning teaching us more about human
intelligence
and intelligence in general yes and the
fact that we see the goal post now
moving
so far away in another planet and so on
is also
um telling us that we do not know enough
about
us because this fact that things that
are easy for us
are hard for computers also means that
we are taking for granted the millions
of years of evolutions that we have
undergone and
i always find it a fascinating tool
research in artificial intelligence
takes inspiration from cognitive science
but taking inspiration only from what we
are now or what we are after
the baby is born so uh in in this
process of growing up and learning
things
after we have been thrown out into the
world uh
is is again saying that
we're not not looking into what
happens before we are born and what
happens
in our revolution as a species and that
we
we perhaps will understand intelligence
when we
really understand biology but if we
when we look at the state of um
biological research
it becomes quite clear that there the
goal post is very far away
therefore i don't expect the our goal
pose to be
closer to us yeah and and what is
intelligence
is it does it have to be this
information conversion ratio does it
have to be sample efficient or
could it be more transactional yeah
um because one of the things that
really interests me actually is is this
idea of being able to create a pure
intelligence like what
jeff hawkins asked i've advocated for or
what go fire people advocate for
and it does make you think that all of
the content that we're creating you need
to be an expert across so many different
fields
right cognitive science statistics
machine learning mathematics
um you know we were talking to michael
bronstein the other week
about group theory for goodness sake
it's it's just mind-boggling
and the philosophy of mind right and um
because can a pure intelligence exist
and then you start to think about
embodiment
and you start to think about um you know
maybe it's an emergent phenomenon
and it just it blows my mind yeah
well it was kind of you know when we
were talking to uh hawkins
and there's the whole sort of is verse
ought dilemma right and and he was
he was kind of saying that uh you know
you don't
you don't necessarily need any kind of
oughts for an intelligence but on the
other hand
let's just say if you just take the
standard kind of scientific view of the
universe and
and leave out some particular
metaphysics
we if if we have oughts human beings
have
moral odds right this came from
inanimate stuff i mean we started off as
just atoms
right and through the process of
cosmic evolution biological evolution we
ended up with odds
so somehow or another at least
physically you can get to
oughts from is even though philosophers
seem to stumble over this all the time
right so
what i'm the reason i'm bringing this up
is that suppose we did create a pure
super intelligence uh i'm not convinced
that it wouldn't
even in its pure form develop odds you
know it may
look out and analyze kind of the what it
can observe in the universe and all the
atoms and biological things that are
around it
and from that arrive at some odds
because look we got here physically
right and we ended up with odds why
can't a pure super intelligence
perhaps it's impossible just from an
energy perspective
think about what energy consumption
would that
being intelligence pure intelligence
need to
overlook everything we even need more
research into physics to
to know if there's a tap into infinite
energy because if there's not i i don't
think
we could pay the energy electricity bill
for that
sure i mean it seems like the primordial
ought
is survival it's like if the if the
super intelligence doesn't survive
then it just won't be around and super
intelligence that do survive
will be and so it just brings about
again the brilliance of
darwin and evolution which is just the
mere requirement of survival almost
produces odds somehow but where i don't
agree with you is the survival aspect
i don't think it's survival itself i
think it's just replication
because if we look at what's driving
living
things i don't think it's survival
itself i mean of course there is a
sense of self-conservation because if
you go kill yourself you're
not producing any more offspring but i
think the
the objective of genes is replication
and not really
surviving i i don't think this
intelligence would be necessarily a
thing that wants to live forever but
perhaps a thing that
knows that it will be able to replicate
forever
yeah i mean obviously for for evolution
the concept of evolution to take place
you have to have those what is it the
four
four kind of components right uh the
ability to pass on information
um i forget what the other ones are but
but you know you might
like you're saying it may be a
combination of things but i think
uh at the end of the day there is this
basic requirement of the ability to
in some form have your information
continue on replicate
and that that could lead to could lead
to odds all kinds of odds
that sort of help achieve that one
primordial art
what do you even think of that paper by
hofstadter you're talking about the uh
the uh his article on analogy is the
core of um of cognition
yeah look i mean
i i think i have a lot of sympathy for
it my my issue is usually
once i get enough interest in something
i want to see math
like okay i buy into this but can we
somehow
formalize this like give me some
symbols that i can start to think about
like here's the structure that defines
what a concept is this is the structure
that defines an analogy
this is the mathematical statement i'm
talking about about how you can derive
all kinds of other reasoning like
syllogisms and whatever else from these
structures
i just want to see some math and a lot
of times there's the philosophy piece
and then nobody ever produces
math and then i then i just kind of stop
it's like okay i think i agree
it sounds pretty good but to really
agree i need some
i need some math to start thinking about
you know
i mean one one thing that did spring to
mind
is there's something very biologically
determined about our intelligence our
intelligence is a function of our own
brain and our own environment and our
own
um you know all of our senses and the
way we interact with environment and so
on
so to a certain extent even our analogy
making is a
is a direct function of our own
embodiment
and the way that our brain is connected
who's to say
that that is a particularly good form of
intelligence i suppose a good form of
intelligence should be one which is
flexible in the sense that one you know
if you have a brain
in a in a would you call it a brain in a
vat
is that right it's completely useless
right
so would our analogy making and the way
our intelligence works is it only
anthropocentric or would it make sense
if our type of intelligence was in a
machine
our anthropocentric is so widespread
and that we're so such i mean because i
agree with you but we are such um
we're prisoners of our we we're
prisoners in our own body and
exactly like you said and i don't think
we would
even recognize such an intelligence
it would be intelligence in some weird
definition that is not anthropocentric
but
what i also understood from the
discussion with melanie mitchell was
that
we do this for a reason it's for helping
us and
if that thing takes off and uh flies off
to
another galaxy that's i mean it could be
intelligence but
that doesn't help us and i also
i'm afraid that really we're not
recognizing sometimes intelligence when
uh
where intelligence is due and i
i mean it's hard now to give an example
and to to put a threshold and to say
dogs are not intelligent but
i know apes are i i would say that
even dogs are intelligent but we're so
anthropocentric and so
prisoners of our own language even that
it's almost sometimes enough to to call
something
either intelligent or either not
intelligent and that thing
will take then this attribute
i mean throughout history we have
labeled mislabeled whole races
as not that intelligent and it's
absolutely it's super dangerous that
that
we could do that successfully without
anyone budging
or not enough people budging for for
such a long time
and on on some aspects we have
enlightened but on other aspects
every time i see a tick tock video with
a dog
that does some interesting things i'm
amazed because
when i read that yes humans are
intelligent
and we're special everything else is not
that special but
i see dogs do things that i wouldn't
have expected
ever so what if uh we're just
mislabeling them
and what if we're doing that with
machines all the time
yeah because what's interesting about
what you just said is
melanie mitchell said that there's the
is it the first step paradox
you know so um it's a
it's a myth to think that intelligence
now is on a ladder to real intelligence
you know like building a taller tower
getting closer to the moon but
interestingly with biological
intelligence there is a continuum
because dogs absolutely are intelligent
so that that's kind of interesting but
what fascinates
me is that because when we talk about
the intelligence explosion and so on you
know charlay argues that there are
limiting
forces there are lots of environmental
rate limiting steps to intelligence but
what fascinates me is that
our own intelligence is anthropocentric
it's very human-like but we've also
discovered mathematics
and we've discovered many universal
paradigms
because a lot of go-fi people they say
that knowledge is universal we acquire
it we don't learn it
so there's this interesting thing that
another form of intelligence could
develop
but they would also acquire and discover
the same
paradigmatic primitives as we have done
so
in a sense this emergent layer of stuff
we've got on the top is completely
disconnected from the intelligence that
discovered it
yeah i agree with you which is so look i
i mean
none of this is binary i don't know why
people always slip back into kind of
binary thinking but yeah humans
human beings have all kinds of issues we
have to eat stuff
and we produce waste and we you know
consume oxygen
and we hurt other human beings and all
kinds of issues but on the other hand
we understand electrons and positrons
and protons and
and neutron stars and we can you know
create models of
of uh parts of the universe that are so
far away that you know we'll probably
never ever
ever be able to reach them so we can
conceive all these things right and we
can create things like mathematics
that uh as far as we know you know
there's no alternatives there's just
math i mean we haven't really discovered
like math one and math two like
the universe was slightly different you
know we would have like math too
um and so i think a lot of what human
intelligence is and a lot of human
knowledge
is universal but on the other hand it's
not all universal
and the hard part is telling which parts
are and aren't
universal and as leticia was saying you
know we do have these cognitive
fallacies where we we oftentimes believe
something
is much more universal than what it
really is it's like one of our friends
tim
is constantly saying you know like oh
you know uh
it was impossible for anybody to believe
that the earth was flat
like ever well hold on a second you know
is the universe flat
i don't know i mean we sort of we've
narrowed it down to a certain uh
you know very tiny tiny tiny degree of
error but still at the same time these
at one time were open questions and yet
there are
reasonings that you can apply to it and
so maybe
reasoning and logic may be more
objective and universal than
that uh some kind of factual knowledge
so i think it's
an open question but i i would guess
that
a large portion of human knowledge is
universal
and not anthropocentric like a
hypothetical super intelligence would
need to understand electrons and protons
and
quantum mechanics and whatever else if
they want to do anything useful
in this universe and then lots of the
stuff we know
is anthropocentric and and not universal
well there's a couple of things there
just to unpack so
some knowledge is universal you can get
into a debate about that a lot of
philosophers are relativists
but let's say we're not a relativist
and then knowledge as we've
previously established is a justified
true
belief but then there's the whole world
of possibilities before you actually
know something is a fact
then you get into this um i mean i would
call it a kind of super set of logical
reasoning but um
our friend would massively disagree with
us on this but sure you know before we
knew
that the earth was round we could
reasonably have believed
that it was flat and what what what
belief is that is it 0.5
is it 0.1 right
about that it's just yes knowledge you
know
at least to epistemologist is a
justified quote true belief but on the
other hand
all of those things justification and
truth
come in degrees it's not zero one the
world is not
binary like it's very hard to think of
things that are even
binary you know i know i i like science
fiction and there's this
quote that always stuck with me from
stargate sg1 which is a tv show
which is this supposed ancient race that
had you know ancient
superior knowledge or whatever they made
this statement that the universe is
infinite is the only truth
right and so there it's almost like
saying there are no absolutes except
this one absolute
right everything else is kind of a
matter of degree
yeah so then when you're building ai
systems
because go-fi people would say knowledge
is acquired
it's not learned you can't you know two
people can't learn it differently again
binary i just can't deal in binaries i'm
not i'm
i
but then how do we build because we we
need common sense knowledge to build ai
right but but we have to
we have to learn it progressively that's
what children do see
that's the amazing thing right is that
we have this brain and as a teacher was
saying
we have all these little cortical
columns and they're all incredibly
um problematic they make errors all the
time but
there's there's so much redundancy and
fault tolerance in our brain
that they actually work really
resiliently and
even though we all learn language and
knowledge differently
we learn it in the same way in the end
right
it's absolutely incredible how that
happens
but are you sure about that i mean have
you checked that uh
you you learn exactly the same way as
keith does
i absolutely love so for me wittgenstein
was an absolute revelation
when i read him and i just love his
analogy to so he has a little story like
everybody walks with a box uh in his
arms
and i can look in my box you can look in
your box but i cannot look
into keith's box or your box and
we we think we're speaking about the
same
thing that and we think we have the same
thing in our box
and we don't and of course there are
some arguments for
perhaps we have the same thing in our
box because if we
you know open the brain it's
a bunch of neurons and there might be
some variants here and there but it's uh
you know the same matter
but we we don't actually know but uh i
mean
it's not a binary thing as keith says
it's
oh nice
it's uh it's not like we are the same
or we're not the same we are on a
distribution
somewhere and we have some deviation
from the from the mean
yeah and actually uh melanie's in some
of her writings
has made this point that you know
communication
between people is metaphor
and it's metaphor in the sense that you
have to so in your mind
if you're doing this or i'm sorry this
is actually in that article by uh
hofstadter actually not this wasn't but
she may have said this to you but
you know if if reasoning has all this
analogy built into it then when i want
to communicate with you and you've got
this different brain
and it's going to be different at least
partially right
not zero or one again but it's going to
be some percentage different
and somehow i have to get my uh analogy
structure that i'm thinking about
communicated over into you and it has to
be encoded in this kind of
language right translated into language
over to you
and then somehow i have to construct in
your mind or
cause to be constructed in your mind
sufficient
analogical structures to recreate what i
have that's a pretty cool thing isn't it
like the fact that we can even do that
and the fact that it works shows that
there has to be
some degree of commonality otherwise
all of us are just not understanding
each other and you know we all do have
you can slice open brains and take a
look and we have a lot of the same
structures
so there's got to be sufficient
commonality
that we can be confident we're thinking
similar enough
right and i think this is again an
evolutionary thing because
we can check that we have a common
understanding by the fact that we then
act um i mean if you say let's go let's
record
we all act in the same way on this
we react right and this is important for
you know the survival of a species that
people start to act together and do
something together but
if again in the line of thinking of
shortcut learning there is no
reason why we should be doing more than
that
than acting on in the same way well one
some yeah one really quick thing here is
there's an even simpler way and this is
actually an important part of debate and
sort of the rules of communication is
i communicate to you and then you have
to communicate back to me
and make sure that it survive the double
translation right which is why you have
these
sort of rappaport rules and whatever
where you know you don't argue with
somebody until you can restate their
position
and they agree that you've accurately
restated their
their position so we just do this back
and forth and make sure that the
translations
are working properly and so much goes
off the rails when people don't take the
time to do that
like this happens to tim and i all the
time like we're in a hurry and
some some discord messages go back and
forth and pretty soon we're not even
talking about the same things
anymore to each other but isn't it
fascinating that we can
actually have this common understanding
at all because intelligence is the
absence of brittleness basically
because our brains are just taking in
hundreds of thousands of little signals
from different parts of our bodies
they're just little sensor predictions
if you believe jeff hawkins
and all of this stuff happens on the top
so now on the top
we have this very robust understanding
when we all say let's do this
let's press the record button and also
another interesting thing as the
symbolists will say
is that most of the knowledge we have
the common sense knowledge is acquired
through deduction
and instruction rather than sensory
experience
so we are communicating with each other
now through instruction
and we're communicating knowledge which
we both have a common understanding of
and much of that knowledge is based on
metaphors
analogy or some kind of experience we've
had in the world
but we've managed to create an abstract
category which robustly lines
up in our theory in our kind of call it
theory of mind
it's it's unbelievable yeah but what i
i think about here is there's shortcut
this is a
matter of shortcut learning in evolution
because
um we always say oh deep learning
network are doing
taking shortcuts and are you know lazy
and so on but i think
evolution does exactly the same thing
because what would be the ideal
communication it would be like in this
avatar movie when
connect their those hair or what they
have they
they connect and they are really
connected and communicate
truly and so on but that didn't happen
and
evolution was lazy here we what we did
was bare minimum such that if you say
let's uh take down this lion we do so
together
and we have a strategy and can we
implement it but it
it's shortcut learning all the way right
it it is it is but the
over kind of uh spread on top
of us is the fact that we had evolution
happening to us and so that's this weird
sort of external process that's doing
all this
you know whatever you want to call it
it's evolutionary evolutionary learning
or
novelty search or whatever where it's
just producing all this variation and
just
absurd amounts of trials of variation
you know that some survive again and
some don't and some replicate and some
don't
and so there's this weird emergent
system that you know system
that's that's also learning like i mean
and i don't want to get into like what
is and isn't learning and this is binary
not learning and that's not learning
but i'm just saying the system as a
whole is accumulating
um information that's accumulating
dna it's accumulating some innate
knowledge that's incumbent
accumulating memes it's it's
accumulating everything
that that leads to what human beings do
and so it's just
you know that that's why like look
machine learning may be doing a lot of
the same things but if you just look in
terms of the amount of like
computation that's going into even
producing gpt3
it's the tiniest tiniest like 10 to the
10th
fraction of the computation that's gone
into producing
the human mind so that's where it's
really not getting a fair shake
it's just that you know if every human
mind is basically this hundred teraflop
thing running on like a very few watts
and there's been a hundred billion
people that have lived and
and even before us how many other
trillions of organisms led up to it
you know there's a lot of learning we
got to do
i want to push back on that just a
little bit because i know you often make
that point but
we have to remember that that was within
biological limitations that was
evolving from nothing from a single cell
organism you know there were all of
these big jumps that had to be
made like when we developed bilateral
symmetry that was a
very interesting evolutionary jump that
happened billions of years ago
and i'm sure that we could create
an artificial intelligence that could
shortcut many of these
um impediments that we had in the
biological
setting i don't i don't disagree with
you
if i could just real quickly respond i
don't disagree with you i'm just saying
that
you know evolution and what it's
produced is over here and
currently machine learning is just
really really far i mean we're only at
the beginnings of it as my only point so
sure we can do shortcuts but we're still
kind of an order of magnitude or maybe
more
or few away from wherever that point is
where
all of our shortcuts are are yielding
enough
to uh produce something that's generally
intelligent yeah and i also agree
that so i talked away now evolution by
saying it's also a form of
shortcut and minimization of energy but
uh
yeah it's it's amazing what a leap it is
because uh
it's way more intricate and not
understood
by us and it's absolutely amazing but i
also think that
it's not the only way of implementing it
especially with this um biological
without a biological constraint it might
look something different
but the problem is we're anthropo
centric and we will say you're thinking
different you are different not
intelligent
i'm afraid we will do that well and i
don't i don't disagree with either of
you so i'm kind of in agreement but i'm
just trying to say
again it's this continuum i'm just
saying artificial
neural networks today as much as people
have made progress
and tweaked activation functions and and
added in some convolution and whatever
else
you know the neurons themselves are
still pretty similar to the abstraction
that was
developed in 1958 right and i'm just
saying
there's at least two or three other
abstractions we could maybe pull out of
the
neocortex that might be useful to us you
know maybe there's a lot more
i'm just saying ever you know as dirty
as evolution is and as
you know all the craft and whatever else
it may or may not have
i think there's still a lot of valuable
processing in there and for me
personally i think it lies in
a lot of the same directions that
melanie thinks which is the temporal
activity so the fact that the brain
is sitting there iterating in this very
complex
temporal dynamics i don't think that was
just ah we gotta biologically do
you know pulsing and temporal
computation if only we could just avoid
that
i think it's actually useful i think
that iterative computation
even some of the non-linear dynamics
that go on in there
are computationally useful and you know
there's mounting evidence of that
uh like you know uh evidence that for
example the apical dendrites and
and what they do uh in creating pulse
you know
pulse firings or burst firing enables
the brain to multiplex and essentially
do this kind of stochastic
back propagation so sure back
propagation may be
better the brain can't do it but maybe
if we can do it in silico it's better
but on the other hand
there may be a lot of dynamics in there
that are providing useful
from an information perspective
computation that we
that we could benefit from if we
incorporate it into
artificial neural networks sure
especially in these
beginning steps i think it's a lot that
we can learn from them but
uh tim you asked before what could an
intelligence look like if it's not
anthropomorphic
what i think about intelligence
ultimately it will be
energy um centric in a sense because all
the biological constraints are in a
sense
energy constraints too kristen would
love to hear you say that
i was just a free energy principle
exactly although i must say that because
i've been speaking a lot with conor
leahy recently and i
i think a lot of it comes down to
computational tractability
because yeah you you could say well we
should have energy constraints and we
should think of intelligence as
you know in an anthropocentric way or we
should think of it in terms of
flexibility but
at the end of the day if you have
infinite amounts of computation
you can do some quite cool things
assuming you believe in computationalism
and
you're not a fan of wittgenstein of
course he wouldn't be
a computationalist i'm sure but you know
i think to a certain extent if you if
you could build a large enough computer
you could do some cool things but
as i pointed out though you have the
problem of markov blankets and
and um you know clearly defined
situations in space it's not like you
could just
build a massive tree search and and just
find some optimal solution
because there'll always be all sorts of
weird things that you can't
um capture in a computer program
one you could always do more with those
same resources like what letitia is
saying here is that
if you pay attention to say optimizing
on energy
constraints or usage or something for
any given amount of resources
maybe you can do more that's kind of
that's kind of point which is just that
okay fine we're going to put together 1
trillion parameters
and then and then we'll be able to do
natural language all right
can you do any more with a trillion
parameters like does it
does it take a trillion parameters to do
natural language or
with that trillion parameters could i do
natural language and play baseball
like is that possible i mean it's just
about being efficient with kind of the
the resources and i think we have a long
long long way to go before we're even
close to
some semblance of information efficiency
yeah and that must come
down because um you know professor
bronstein and
taka kohen and all these geometric deep
learning guys they talk about symmetries
and invariants
and melanie mitchell was talking about
abstract categories
it's all the same thing right it's all
about being able to take a lot of
information and compress it
that's what we need to be able to do in
some very deep way that i
i don't understand but i really wish i
did because it's really cool
yeah but this closes down the circle
into responding with
intelligence is about efficiency because
if an intelligence will be
ultimately only limited by energy then
efficiency
is intelligence because it's how you use
that limited energy to
do stuff in the world i agree with you
but for the record some people really
disagree
with that they they say no no no it's
not about efficiency it's about
you know information conversion or
whatever else but i think the
one of the fairest gauges of
intelligence is really
efficiency it's like that way if you
give me a black box
and it does something and i can measure
how efficiently it does that
i can decide how intelligent it is i
don't really need to know
its inner workings and how long it took
it to teach it how to do that
and how much prior knowledge it has i
don't care i just care how many watts
did it take to
how many watts you know in time or
whatever
did it take to achieve that and then
then i know if it's intelligent
awesome well fine people it's been an
amazing podcast
i've really enjoyed myself and it's the
weekend
oh yeah good thank you for reminding me
that's
that makes him much happier now
seriously i've had a lot of fun so
leticia and keith thanks so much for
joining us for the for the debrief and
i'm really looking forward to getting
this out
thanks for having us thank you amazing
teach here thank you